Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Heute machen wir aber mal eine ganz friedliche Sendung, oder?
Lieber Tim, da Norwegen beschlossen hat, mir den Friedensnobelpreis nicht zu
verleihen, fühle ich mich nicht mehr verpflichtet, ausschließlich an den Frieden zu denken.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 543 vom 21.
Januar 2026 und was sollen wir euch sagen, Leute? Wir kommen in Frieden.
Also ich, da fehlt oft die Logik.
Wenn man den nicht bekommt, muss man nicht mehr nur in Frieden denken.
Was ist denn, wenn man den bekommt?
Den Friedensnobelpreis, dann verschenkt man den.
Dann müssen wir dem Donald Trump schenken, ja.
Das ist so wütendig. Also ich finde, also ich meine mal ehrlich,
2026 lässt sich doch ganz gut an, oder?
Also immer wenn man so denkt, das letzte Jahr war jetzt aber echt wild.
Kommt direkt so, patsch.
Stell dir mal vor, das nächste Jahr würde jetzt so total langweilig werden. Und nichts passiert.
Und dann BAM! Also ich meine, insofern ist auf Donald Trump wirklich Verlass.
Der will Show, der liefert auch Show. Aber wie das so generell ist mit Fernsehen,
man sollte es halt nicht so ernst nehmen.
Naja,
okay.
Erklär es mal den Grönländern. Komm, Fernsehen muss nicht ernst nehmen.
Der tut nichts, der will nur spielen.
Die Grönländer, die haben so einen geilen Sticker gesehen, wo drauf stand so,
Maga, make America go away.
Also, weißt du, man muss auch ein bisschen mit Humor kontern,
aber du hast natürlich auch recht, also sowohl mit Lächerlichkeit,
also die geben sich ja quasi selber der Lächerlichkeit preis und das sollte
man dann auch kanalisieren, dass diese Preisgebung auch wahrgenommen wird.
Aber andererseits sollte man halt nicht so sehr in den Arsch kriechen und ich
denke, das wäre so ein bisschen mein Wunsch für dieses Jahr,
dass sich so die freie Welt nicht so bemüht, ihm irgendwie noch die Lippen da
zu massieren, sondern einfach sagt so, Leute, bis hierhin und nicht weiter.
Hast du die Rede von dem kanadischen Ministerpräsidenten jetzt in Davos schon mitbekommen?
Das war jetzt erst kurz vor der Sendung Ne.
Hab ich nicht mitbekommen Der Kani.
Der hat's ja auch wirklich alle beisammen und der ohne Trump oder die USA auch
nur wörtlich zu erwähnen, fing halt irgendwie an und meint so,
ja Leute, macht euch jetzt keine Illusionen mehr,
alte Ordnung alte Weltordnung ist jetzt
halt vorbei und hat dann irgendwie ausgeführt, dass die Mittelmächte,
die freien Mittelmächte, sich jetzt hier mal zusammenschließen sollten gegen
die Großmächte, weil die kommen gerade nicht so richtig klar und das war im
Prinzip eine volle Absage an,
das alte Bündnis.
Also das war jetzt mal wirklich sehr explizit.
Da hat er dann auf jeden Fall wie ich finde, Schwarze getroffen.
Der Rest eiert halt noch so ein bisschen rum.
Ich habe nur das Bild gesehen, dass mir,
wo ich, also ich hoffe, das war jetzt keine AI, sonst wird derjenige,
der es mir geschickt hat, sich jetzt sehr sportlachen, wo Trump sitzt und vor
ihm sitzen so irgendwie von der Leyen, Macron,
wie heißt unser Vogel?
März und so und er hat da im Hintergrund so eine Weltkarte wo die USA drauf
ist und dann so eingekleidet mit einer Flagge und darüber dann Kanada und Alaska
und Grönland und alles so das.
War glaube ich echt,
Naja, es soll halt provozieren, das ist alles, worum es geht.
Ich hoffe, das geht halt mal in die, also ich bin mal gespannt, bei anderen,
sagen wir mal,
Staatenlenkern der Geschichte, hat man auch sehr lange gesagt,
die wollen nur provozieren.
Arscharf am Godwin vorbei. Ich meine ja zum Beispiel Barack Obama, der alte Provokateur.
Am Ende hat er tatsächlich seine Drohung wahrgemacht und Krankenversicherung für alle eingeführt.
Ich sage ja auch nicht, dass das nicht am Ende auch alles so exekutiert werden soll.
Selbstverständlich sind das explizit seine Wünsche. Er benennt sie ja dann doch
sehr klar. Man muss dem halt nur sehr klar entgegenstehen und sagen,
ja, schöne Meinung, die sie da haben, aber sorry, findet nicht statt.
Natürlich haben jetzt alle Schiss und das ist ja auch nachvollziehbar,
so wegen der ganzen Wirtschaft und dem Geld und dem Wohlstand und so weiter.
Das wird uns hart treffen, aber die Dinge bewegen sich so und am Ende muss halt
Europa zusammenfinden und wieder eine Einheit werden,
die Briten wieder reinholen und neue Modelle aufkommen lassen und halt einfach,
ja Independence Day ist ja voll angesagt.
Das brauchen wir jetzt halt auch von den USA.
Ich erinnere mich übrigens gerade dass du, ich weiß nicht ob du es absichtlich
gemacht hast ich wollte nur sagen, ich habe es erkannt, du hast eine der wichtigsten Filmszenen,
referenziert in deinem Schöne Meinung haben sie da,
Big Lebowski, Nobody Fucks With The Jesus?
Die habe ich jetzt nicht so explizit benannt, aber du hast natürlich recht,
dass das eine der besten Szenen ist.
Well, yeah.
That's just your opinion, man.
Ja, in der Tat. The Dude hat es auf jeden Fall Kapiert irgendwie, ja.
Und ja, ich finde auch irgendwie,
wenn einem so ein schlecht frisierter Volltrampel einem auf den Teppich pisst,
dann And I tell you, the rug really tied the room together.
Okay Gut, das haben wir bewiesen, dass wir die voll die geilen Cineasten sind,
Vor allem einfach einen Film hunderttausend Mal geguckt Ja und das befähigt
uns natürlich die gesamte Weltpolitik durchgehend zu kommentieren This.
Aggression will not stand,
Das Spiel gewinne ich. Ich bin da sehr geübt drin.
Ja, ich auch.
Wir hatten ein alter Arbeitskollege von mir,
wir hatten über eine längere Zeit dieses Spielchen im Arbeitsalltag möglichst
viele Zitate aus diesem Film anzubringen.
Also zum Beispiel so You want a toe? I can get you a toe. I can get you a nail polish.
Aber es musste halt auch passen. Das konntest du nicht einfach so machen.
Aber das ist erstaunlich, wie viel Kommunikation eines Tages man so einfach
in den Bickel rausgezogen kann.
Absolut. Da ist es definitiv ein Film, der alles hergibt, was man so braucht
für die tinkliche Konversation.
Da kann man fast einen ganzen Podcast mit bestreiten.
Ja.
Sogar einen, der sich vorgibt, sich mit Netzpolitik zu beschäftigen.
Ja, wollen wir dann mal so ein
bisschen die News abgraben? So richtig viel passiert ist ja gar nicht mal.
Außer, dass die Rotary-Hilfe ihr Konto erstmal wieder hat.
Ja, zumindest vorerst, wie Logbuch Netzpolitik berichtete, Trump war ja der
Meinung, er müsste jetzt mal hier Antifa Ost und so weiter auf die Terrorlisten schreiben,
wo dann die Banken gleich angefangen haben zu zittern, dass sie jetzt aus dem
internationalen Geldtransfer ausgeschlossen werden.
Und abgesehen von den Debatten, die das im Hinblick von Souveränität mit sich bringt,
haben dann verschiedene Organisationen darunter leiden müssen,
unter anderem eben die Rote Hilfe e.V.
Und jetzt gab es eine einstweilige Verfügung des Landgerichts Göttingen,
das hatte die Rote Hilfe beantragt in dem wurde jetzt stattgegeben,
sodass jetzt zumindest vorerst dieses Konto fortgeführt werden muss.
Und ja, ganz interessant, also das Gericht hat das dann mündlich begründet,
meinte so, dass irgendwie politische Entscheidungen oder Listungen eines x-beliebigen
Drittstaats keine ausreichende Grundlage für die Kündigung eines Kontos durch
ein deutsches Kreditinstitut darstellen.
X-beliebiger Drittstaat, sehr schöne Formulierung.
Vor allem das X da noch, wenn das X da noch sein.
Genau, auch die Beobachtung des Vereins durch den Verfassungsschutz selbst stellt
jetzt auch erstmal keinen Grund dar, so ein Konto zu kündigen.
Der freut sich die AfD.
Ja, könnt ihr erstmal Konto behalten. Ficker.
Alright, ja, ist doch mal ganz schön. einstweilige Verfügungen,
Und rechtskräftig, wenn man es nicht anfechtet. Die einstweilige Verfügung ist
ja in diesem Fall auch das richtige Mittel,
dass du nämlich ein unmittelbares Urteil des Gerichtes anstrebst aufgrund der dringenden Eile.
Und die einstweilige sich der zu widersetzen, führt dann eben zum unmittelbaren Gerichtsverfahren.
Aber weil quasi der Schaden unmittelbar
ist und abwendbar sein muss und um deine Interessen zu schonen,
quasi wenn eine ausreichende Aussicht darauf besteht, dass deine Interessen
hier verletzt werden und du einen fortwährenden Schaden hast,
der nur größer wird, auch wenn du vielleicht irgendwann einmal Recht bekommst,
dann nimmst du eine einstweilige.
Kann aber sein, also würde nun die Sparkasse Göttingen sagen,
Nein, die Penner wollen wir nicht und wir gehen jetzt vor das Gericht.
Dann könnte es immer noch sein, dass in einer Hauptverhandlung ein anderes Ergebnis
kommt. Aber es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich bei einer einstweiligen.
Also zumindest ist das ja auch erstmal so eine Schnelleinschätzung und das sagt
ja auch schon ein bisschen was darüber aus, wie das Gericht so grundsätzlich über den Fall denkt.
Gut, schön.
So eine kleine Kleinigkeit, die mir über den Weg gelaufen ist.
Eine schöne Webseite, die heißt leavex, wo wir schon bei x beliebigen Drittstaaten waren, leavex.eu.
Das ist eine ganz putzige Webseite, die eigentlich wesentlich eine Datenbank-Suche ist.
Über alle Mitglieder des Europäischen Parlaments mit der Information,
ob die noch einen Account auf X haben oder nicht.
Beziehungsweise wenn sie einen haben, ob sie ihn benutzen.
60% haben einen.
60% haben einen, ja genau. Ja, 421 haben einen, 7 haben einen,
den sie nicht nutzen und 291 haben keinen.
Oder zumindest behauptet das diese Webseite. Ich weiß natürlich jetzt nicht,
wie viele Bücher die sich da gegeben haben, aber die lüsten das dann alles gleich auf.
Man kann dann auch suchen. Ich habe mal so kurz geguckt, wie das mit unseren
deutschen Vertretern so aussieht.
Und wenn die Suche richtig funktioniert hat, haben wir so bei CDU,
CSU 25 Accounthalter, bei der SPD 4,
wir neun keinen haben und einer, also die mittleren, die nicht aktiven,
unterschlage ich jetzt einfach mal, FDP 6 zu 2, Grüne 10 zu 3 und die AfD 3 zu 12.
Linke 2 zu 2. Mit anderen Worten, die Grünen sind so voll, voll auf X. Und die AfD nicht so.
Die sind auf TikTok und hetzen da die Kinder auf.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Naja, gut.
Insgesamt ist Deutschland, aber ja, Deutschland ist im europäischen Mittelfeld mit 55 Aktiven.
Das sind 61 Prozent.
Also, ja, ziemlich genau im Durchschnitt.
Wieder am Ende vielleicht nicht so in die Rolle. Ich meine, man muss dazu sagen,
diese,
Forderung, Plattformen zu verlassen und so, klar, kann man alles machen,
ist ja auch sehr gut nachvollziehbar.
Haben ja auch schon über X berichtet, insbesondere mit ihren jüngsten,
Grog Geschichten.
Das sollte auf jeden Fall Leute nochmal dazu bringen, zu überlegen,
ob das jetzt wirklich so das Ding ist.
Aber es ist natürlich auch so, dass quasi das Weltgeschehen in dem Sinne auf
dieser Plattform nach wie vor diskutiert wird.
Es ist halt einfach immer noch der Politkrieg, Konflikt, Journalisten, Politiker-Kanal.
Selbst wenn einem das nicht recht ist. Und ich wäre auch nicht überrascht,
wenn es noch eine ganze Menge mehr Accounts gibt, die bloß nicht so eindeutig zuzuordnen sind.
Das sind hier nicht so offizielle.
Ein Shadow-Account. Aber die, das ist richtig...
Aber das ist ja so ein klassisches kollektives Problem.
Jedes M-D-E-P, was bei X ist, trägt auch zu der Relevanz dieser Plattform bei.
Gleichermaßen ist es für jedes einzelne M-D-E-P wahrscheinlich schwierig zu
sagen, ich verlasse diese Plattform mit dieser Relevanz.
Und das kannst du ja nur auflösen, indem man beispielsweise mal gemeinsam einen Effort macht.
Und das könnte ja zum Beispiel sein, dass nicht in jedem dritten Artikel auf
tagesschau.de ein X-Post eingebettet ist.
Und einer der Gründe, warum die da eingebettet sind, ist, dass es die gibt.
Und einer der Gründe, dass es die gibt, ist, dass die Tagesschau die dann auch einbettet.
Sodass irgendwo muss man dann eben mal anfangen, so einen Trend loszutreten.
Ja, und das muss eben in der Regel idealerweise konzertiert sein.
Ich twitter das nochmal.
Ich habe auch meinen Account da auch noch.
Ja klar, ich habe ja keinen Bock, dass das jetzt irgendwie jemand den Username nimmt.
Das ist einer dieser Gründe, also einfach nur, um da mal sein Handtuch ausgelegt zu haben.
Und es ist auch für mich nach wie vor eine Quelle, allerdings ist es für mich
keine Quelle aus so Daily Use, also ich lese meine Timeline nicht.
Ich habe auch diese App nicht installiert,
weil die unbenutzbar ist und dementsprechend ist es für mich...
Nur wegen der Interviews, ne?
Nur wegen der Bilder.
Okay. Die...
Diese Webseite, das sollte man noch kurz sagen, die unterscheidet ja auch nach
hat einen Account und der Account wird aktiv genutzt.
Da kriegst du Punkte für,
Handtuch. Handtuch ist nicht ganz so schlimm wie,
gestern noch mit Elon Musk irgendwie gegen Beleidigungen ausgetauscht.
So, ganz viel Unabhängigkeit haben wir heute im Thema.
Ja, Erich Möchel hat mal recherchiert, dass Österreich interessanterweise so
langsam, aber sicher dann doch relativ große,
Migrationserfolge so bekannt gibt.
Zum Beispiel ist das Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft vollständig auf Nextcloud umgezogen und.
Das Heer ist auf LibreOffice, migriert mit 16.000 Accounts und da gibt es dann
eine Deklaration zur europäischen digitalen,
Souveränität.
Da hat Österreich dann eben mal ernst genommen und hat gesagt,
okay, machen wir jetzt mal.
Und zwar haben sie ja wirklich auch was auf der Roadmap. So ein Nextcloud statt Sharepoint.
Dann als nächstes von der VMware rausschmeißen und Proxmox nehmen.
Proxmox ist eine Open Source oder Quell auf freie frei weiß ich nicht genau, was die Lizenz ist.
Also so eine Linux-basierte, nicht mit Lizenzgebühren verhaftete Virtualisierungslösung,
Dann wollen sie MS SQL rauswerfen. Das ist da auch wirklich,
also das ist, finde ich, immer noch das Unnötigste. Ein Microsoft SQL Server.
Das ist wirklich unnötig.
Also da denkt man sich, das ist unnötig. Das ist eine völlig bekloppte Architekturentscheidung.
Warum würde man einen Microsoft SQL Server nehmen?
Ja, also der hat ja keine besonderen Qualitäten und du hast die Lizenzkosten
auf Ewigkeit am Arsch, weil eine Datenbank irgendwo drin hängen zu haben,
ist auf jeden Fall unschön.
Und das ist, Datenbank-Migrationen sind auch echt, irgendwas ist immer. Ja, dass du dann, also.
Das verstehe ich nicht. Und von
Exchange wollen sie auch mal weg auf Open Exchange und Thunderbird und so.
Also die machen da jetzt, die Österreicher machen das einfach jetzt.
Und finde ich da mal ganz gut.
Ja, ich bin mal gespannt, ob das den nächsten Regierungswechsel auch überlebt
oder ob sie dann nicht sagen, jetzt steigen wir dann doch wieder auf Vorkontakte um oder so.
Also das,
aber ist gut ich meine es gibt wahrscheinlich eine Menge,
Umstellungs Stress für alle Beteiligten das ist nicht mal von eben,
das ist nicht so jetzt installierst du dir Open Source und dann ist alles super,
sondern werden sie erstmal alle ein paar Jahre fluchen darüber,
weil erstmal ist alles anders Ja.
Anders wollen wir nicht.
Anders ist generell immer der Feind des Neuen so und dann ist halt auch, naja,
sicherlich muss auch diese Software sich dann anpassen an diese neuen Umgebungen,
in denen sie bisher so noch nicht viel genutzt wurde.
Ja, also wenn das österreichische Heer demnächst versehentlich in Grönland einfällt, dann...
Das ist aber bei jeder Migration so. Das war auch bei dem Einrichten der Microsoft-Produkte
so. Aber ja, es ist eine Änderung.
Und wir kennen ja auch die historischen Limux und so, wo dann irgendwie,
also sowas will gut geplant und gut exekutiert sein.
Nicht unbedingt, weil das andere Tool, die andere Plattform besser,
schlechter, teurer, grüner, blauer ist, sondern weil sie ist eben anders.
Und mit Änderungen mögen die Leute nicht so. Oder Änderungen müssen sehr gut begleitet werden.
Und wenn du jetzt irgendwie plötzliche Änderungen hast und die zu schnell zu
viele Änderungen machst und dadurch irgendwie Produktivität oder Abläufe leiden,
dann hast du in Konsequenz einen Backlash, dann wirst du vielleicht die Änderungen nicht hinkriegen.
Aber umso beeindruckender, dass sie das machen.
Die Meldung gibt jetzt, so wie sie uns hier vorliegt, ein bisschen wenig Kontext
in Bezug auf, wie sie das denn machen wollen. Weil es ist halt nicht getan,
indem du einfach jetzt nur andere Software aufspielst oder vielleicht deine
Dokumente konvertiert bekommst.
Das ist halt erstmal rein jetzt vom Bestand her schwierig.
Du musst ja Daten konvertieren, Protokolle, Zugriffe.
Die ganzen Arbeitsabläufe müssen sich anpassen. Aber vor allem muss ja auch
diese Software eigentlich, eigentlich muss sowas alles aus einer, ähm.
Regierungsoptimierten Distributionen kommen. Also eigentlich müsste ja das Land
Und da bist du bei Microsoft richtig?
Nein, ich rede ja jetzt nicht von Microsoft, sondern ich rede halt dieses Paket,
was man benötigt, um auf Bundes,
Landes, kommunaler Ebene auch alle Werkzeuge zu haben, wo dann auch alle Gesetze
berücksichtigt sind, wo auch alle Prozesse abbildbar sind.
Das muss ja das Ziel sein und deswegen warte ich jetzt eigentlich auf entsprechende
Initiativen dass halt diese Länder,
das gilt genauso gut für Deutschland und im Prinzip gilt das dann auch, finde ich,
letztlich auch auf einer EU-Ebene dass man anfängt wirklich Teams aufzustellen
die quasi an fertigen Distributionen dafür arbeiten die also wirklich,
Also ich verstehe.
Was du meinst Also schauen wir mal, was haben sie hier, also die Erfolge sind,
das Heer geht auf LibreOffice, okay, jetzt kann man sagen, wie viele Briefe
tippen denn so die österreichischen Soldaten an der Front nach Hause mit einem Office-Produkt?
Also ich würde vermuten, dass wahrscheinlich relativ wenige der Geschäftsprozesse
eines Heeres kritische Abhängigkeitspfade auf Office haben.
Du bist ja sehr optimistisch.
Kann sein, dass ich mich vertue. Vielleicht müssen die auch die ganze Zeit irgendwie
Excel-Tabellen klicken oder so. Weiß ich nicht.
Wenn du einen Datenbestand dann in die anderen Formate, das ist mit Ruckeleien verbunden,
Ich weiß nicht, ob die jetzt einen kompletten Government-Stack brauchen,
weil sie werden natürlich sicherlich auch noch eine Reihe anderer Applikationen
haben, mit denen sie da ihr Herr managen oder was. Was weiß ich.
Krankheitsplan, Schlachtplan, Kantinenplan oder so. Das ist ja alles dann,
das ist immer eine dedicated Salesforce-Instanz oder sowas. Und dann haben sie,
in dem Wirtschaftsministerium Nextcloud. Da ist schon eher, da würdest du vermuten,
okay, so ein Wirtschaftsministerium wird dann auch irgendwie Text schreiben, kollaborativ und so.
Da glaube ich schon, dass die mehr klassische Standardprozesse ihrer Tätigkeit dort abbilden müssen.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, wir haben den Gesetzgebungsprozess inklusive Bund-Länder-Koordination
jetzt auf, weiß ich nicht, EMAX umgestellt.
Also das sind ja noch relativ...
Wahrscheinlich Nischenprodukte.
Das ist schon klar. Es sind jetzt vor allem auch generische Produkte,
die typische Vorgänge wie ich schreibe einen Brief, ich mache eine Tabelle,
ich schreibe eine Mail und so weiter abbilden.
Aber es ist ja auch, man will ja jetzt auch in so einem Apparat,
vor allem nicht in einem militärischen Apparat jetzt, dass die Leute dann irgendwie,
ihren Brief irgendwie auf Laufwerk C in Brief1.doc abspeichern, sondern...
Ja, alles in die Cloud.
Ich meine, natürlich gibt es auch Betriebssoftware, auch die muss ja letztlich
Open Source werden und das ist einfach ein Vorhaben, was nicht in ein,
zwei Jahren zu machen ist,
sondern was perspektivisch ja ewig so weitergeht.
Wir müssen uns generell an diesen Gedanken gewöhnen, dass wir,
wenn man jetzt diesem Souveränitätsbegriff folgen möchte,
dass die Länder ihre informatische Infrastruktur genauso in der Hand haben wie
alles andere auch und dazu gehört einfach ein Big Plan und viele Teams und eine
internationale Zusammenarbeit allein schon im Hinblick auf europäische Harmonisierung etc.
Und dann kann da was draus werden.
Was macht Berlin? Genau und jetzt, also ich muss sagen, man muss mich mal kurz
kneifen, Moment, ich kneife mich mal kurz selbst.
Berlin hat ein Strategiepapier vorgelegt mit dem Titel Open Source Strategie
für das Land Berlin, digitale Souveränität und Innovationskraft stärken.
Ihr merkt schon, CDU ist in der Regierung, deswegen muss das Wort Innovation
da drin vorkommen, aber...
Aber was in diesem PDF steht, ist in der Tat überraschend.
Weil sie hier dann mal festhalten, dass surprise, surprise, unter anderem geopolitische
Spannung jetzt sie dann doch zum Handeln zwingen.
Also das ist das offizielle Eingeständnis, wir haben Schiss.
Und allerlei uns seit längerem bekannte Buzzwords dann auf einmal nach oben
babbeln wie Public Money, Public Code und ja, ich zitiere mal hier einen Absatz.
Der anbieterseitige Zwang, Hersteller-Cloud-Systeme mit den damit einhergehenden,
erheblichen und nahezu unverhandelbaren Lizenzbedingungen und Kosten beziehen
zu müssen, ist aus Sicht des Landes Berlin ein schwerwiegender Grund,
sich mit Alternativen zu den IT-Systemen von marktdominierenden Herstellern auseinanderzusetzen.
Die Lizenzpolitiken großer Monopolisten und Hyperscaler sind als kritisch bzw.
Sehr problematisch einzuordnen. Neben sehr hohen Lizenzkosten schränken die
unerwünschten Funktionalitäten wie Produktaktivierungen in großem Umfang,
Telemetrie, Datenabflüsse aus den verwendeten Produkten sowie die Aufwände und
potenzielle Konsequenzen von Lizenzauditierungen die Handlungsfähigkeit entscheidend ein.
Ein Umstieg auf digitale, souveräne IT-Produkte ergibt sich daher schon aus
diesen Gründen zwingend.
Ja, sehr schön. Aber eine Lizenz-Auditierung. Das ist doch auch so geil, ne?
Das ist ja wirklich ein Business-Model.
Kannst du da mal den Begriff aufschlüsseln? Den höre ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt
das erste Mal. Was ist denn eine Lizenz-Auditierung?
Naja, dass halt geguckt wird, also ich würde das so interpretieren,
dass halt auch geprüft wird.
Ob sie bei einer haben. Ob du denn berechtigt bist.
Ob der Microsoft Windows XP nicht hier mit YKGW diesen einen der das,
dass die Lizenzen, die du da geklickt hast, zu dem Leistungs- und Nutzerinnenumfang
gehören, den du da so verwendest.
Und interessanterweise sind Lizenzierungen bei fortgeschrittenen Produkten so
komplex, dass sie geeignet sind,
dass du schnell entweder dagegen verstößt oder zu viel hast.
Oder sie sind so gebündelt, dass du halt bestimmte Pakete kaufen musst.
Microsoft zum Beispiel hat ja dann, ich bin zum Glück nicht in diesem ganzen
Beschaffungswesen drin.
Aber ich weiß, dass es Firmen gibt, die sich darauf spezialisieren,
die Software-Nutzung von Unternehmen, zum Beispiel, was nicht nur Microsoft,
auch so schöne Sachen wie SAP oder so.
Zu analysieren und für die Workflows und den Bedarf, den sie haben,
günstigere Lizensierungen und Pakete zu finden.
Und ich hätte jetzt nicht gedacht, dass das überhaupt etwas ist, aber es ist etwas.
Es gibt ein Unternehmen, mehrere Unternehmen, die zum Beispiel auch so deine
Cloud-Kosten dann reduzieren.
Und die pitchen das als, wir machen es kostenlos.
Mit anderen Worten, die lassen sich quasi erfolgsbasiert bezahlen.
Und sagen, wir reduzieren deine jährlichen Kosten um 10%.
Und davon hätten wir gerne 1% oder sowas.
Da ist wirklich was drin, dass dieser Lizenz-Dschungel so wild ist,
dass man sich da als Unternehmen nicht drin zurechtfindet.
Und allein das finde ich schon äußerst unterhaltsam. ja, gleichermaßen,
klar, das war vor 10 Jahren haben alle gesagt, ja guck mal wen wir hier alles
rausschmeißen können, wenn wir den Shit in die Cloud kippen und dann haben sie
halt irgendwann gemerkt, oh wird irgendwie teurer und oh jetzt haben wir diesen
Login-Effekt und oh, das sind jetzt Ewigkeitskosten, das zahlen wir jeden Monat ne,
ich, je nachdem was du machst, ist das natürlich sehr verlockend.
Bestimmte Dinge eher als Service zu konsumieren, haben wir ja auch hier zum
Thema AWS Outage und Signal drüber gesprochen.
Aber sehr schön, dass Sie sagen, es ist zwingend erforderlich. Ist es ja auch.
Wir haben uns die ganze Zeit überlegt, wir haben uns, Tim, stell dir mal vor,
wir haben die ganze Zeit gedacht, wir werden irgendwann von China angegriffen
und die schalten den Mobilfunk ab.
Jetzt stell dir aber mal vor, wir werden von Amerika angegriffen und die Berliner
Behörden stehen still. Oh, wait.
Es gibt auch Leute, die behaupten, das wäre schon passiert.
Man kann es nicht so richtig messen. Das Papier gibt im Übrigen auch noch ein Ziel aus und das heißt,
es sollen bis 2032, also binnen von sechs Jahren oder fünf Jahren,
je nachdem wie man das liest,
sollen 70 Prozent des Software-Stacks des typischen IKT, also Informations-
und Kommunikationstechnologie-Arbeitsplatzes, auf Open-Source-Software umgestellt sein.
Das klingt noch nicht mal komplett unrealistisch. Wenn man das will,
dann könnte man das in der Zeit tatsächlich hinbekommen.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie die die 70% berechnen, aber wir jetzt auch nicht in
die Haare spalten gehen.
Naja, Hauptsache man hat ein Ziel, das ist ja schon mal was.
War jetzt Berlin nicht unbedingt so bekannt für so viele Maßnahmen.
Ja, kurzer Blick nach Tschechien. Da gab es eine Entscheidung des obersten Gerichtshofs.
Und wenn ich das richtig verstehe, bedeutet das in deren System quasi so verfassungsmäßig
das Höchste, was du da an gerichtlicher Aussage bekommen kannst.
Aber I don't know, um ehrlich zu sein. Auf jeden Fall hat dieser oberste Gerichtshof
die Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
die in diesem Land aktiv betrieben wurde, für rechtswidrig erklärt und einfach
festgestellt, dass anlasslose und flächendeckende Speicherung nur in Ausnahmefällen zulässig sei.
Und da würde ja noch nicht mal der Krieg in der Ukraine als Begründung ausreichen,
was unter anderem natürlich auch angeführt wurde von den Unterstützern.
Und außerdem würde das ja gegen die E-Privacy-Richtlinie der EU verstoßen.
Da gab es eine entsprechende Klage gegen diese tschechische Vorratsdatenspeicherung
von einem Journalisten und der Datenschutzorganisation Juridicum Remedium.
Jure, die hatten wir glaube ich noch nie erwähnt.
Ja, das war wohl jetzt erfolgreich.
Interessant auch, dass das Gericht meint, dass das bloße Gefühl des Überwachtwerdens
und der damit einhergehende Kontrollverlust über die eigenen Daten könne ja
schon einen entschädigungspflichtigen immateriellen Schaden darstellen.
Also schadensersatzpflichtig quasi.
Interessante Position an der Stelle und nicht nur so ein reines,
ja, ne, könnt ihr jetzt nicht machen,
sondern wenn ihr das macht, dann verstoßt ihr so sehr gegen die Rechte der Menschen,
das quasi wie eine Schadenswirkung aufgefasst werden kann, die dann eben auch
vielleicht schadensersatzpflichtig wäre.
Okay.
Ja. Dann haben wir noch ein bisschen was zu AI, weil heute darf kein Podcast
ohne das Thema ausgeliefert werden.
Sonst lohnen sich ja die ganzen Investitionen, die wir da jetzt gemacht haben, nicht.
Und zwar so eine negative Auswirkung. Ich meine, dass wir das auch schon mal,
das kann sein, haben wir das, glaube ich, wir hatten nochmal diese längere Sendung
oder tatsächlich sogar zwei Sendungen mit der Feedback-Sendung dazu,
wo wir uns so im letzten Sommer so über AI mal an sich unterhalten haben und
wo wir mal ein bisschen geglaskugelt haben und uns mal ein bisschen festgelegt haben.
Und was ganz interessant sein wird, das mal in ein paar Jahren nachzuhören,
ob wir denn überhaupt auch nur ansatzweise recht gehabt haben mit unseren Aussagen.
Aber ich meine, dass es da schon mal anklang. Also, wovon rede ich jetzt?
Das Projekt Curl, das wird jetzt vielleicht vielen von euch erstmal nichts sagen
und allen anderen eine ganze Menge. Curl ist so eine Computerprogrammierlibrary
oder auch ein Kommandozeilentool.
In dem Curl steckt URL mit drin, das ist die Hauptaufgabe dieses Tools gewesen,
sprich auf der Kommandozeile eines Computers kann man dann mal so eben sagen,
hier lad mal, was auch immer der Webserver unter dieser URL ausspuckt und zeig
mir das an, speichere mir das ab und so weiter.
Also extrem universelles Tool, was auch mittlerweile deutlich über diesen Bereich
hinausgeht, auch irgendwie unzählige an Protokollen unterstützt.
Also so eine Art Schweizer Taschenmesser für die Kommandozeile,
um irgendwie so mit dem Web und dem Internet an sich zu arbeiten,
wenn es um Netzwerkprotokolle geht. Und die hatten wie so manche Projekte eine Bug-Bounty.
Das heißt, wenn man da einen tollen Fehler drin findet, dann wurde das auch
entlohnt. Also mit Geld und so.
Und das wird aber jetzt zum Ende des Januars eingestellt, weil...
Naja, jetzt alle ihre AIs anschmeißen, den Code draufwerfen und dann irgendwelche
ausführlichen, angeblichen Fehlerberichte generieren, die halt auf der einen
Seite entweder gar keine richtigen Fehler sind, sondern nur so irgendwelche herbei,
vielleicht nicht unbedingt halluzinierten, aber stark interpretierungswürdige
Betrachtungen von Sicherheit enthalten.
Und dann natürlich darauf aus waren, vor allem diese Kohle abzuziehen,
also nicht wirklich hilfreich waren und das Projekt ist damit halt einfach komplett
geflutet worden und sagt, das hat so alles überhaupt gar keinen Sinn,
deswegen lassen wir das jetzt sein.
Das ist definitiv keine schöne Entwicklung.
Ja, ich mache mir gerade Sorgen, wie viele Kommentare jetzt kommen und die Bedeutung
von Libcurl betonen gegenüber, was du sagst, ein Kommandozeilen-Tool.
Tatsächlich, glaube ich, ist die viel häufigere Anwendung von Curl als Library
in irgendeinem Softwarepaket,
dass du eben beispielsweise HTTP oder auch LDAP, IMAP und alles mögliche,
SFTP, SMB, was nicht alles sprechen kannst.
Also eine Reihe von Protokollen, die häufig halt, ja.
23 Protokolle.
Oh, sehr gut.
Ich habe sie gezählt.
Ja, der Entwickler ist sowieso relativ Daniel Stenberg, relativ aktiv,
also sowieso in der Community bekannt.
Natürlich ist er eben auch der Maintainer einer Software, die sehr,
sehr, sehr viel Verbreitung hat, weil ja die meisten Tools in irgendeiner Weise
mit anderen Computern reden.
Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man dafür die Curl-Library benutzt,
ist jetzt nicht so gering.
Und er hat schon länger sich darüber, also der hat das so auf Mastodon und so,
habe ich den einen schon länger behandelt, dass ihn das halt nervt,
dass irgendwelche Bots, Bug-Bounties versuchen abzugreifen und so.
Und dass er jetzt quasi, sobald er nicht mehr Bounty steht, ist seine Hoffnung,
dass er die Bots los ist, weil natürlich keiner Tokens dafür ausgibt,
irgendwo Bugs zu fallen, wo man kein Bounty dafür kriegt.
Ja.
Ja, und dann schalten wir jetzt oben zum Sport.
Zum Sport. Ja, zum Sport. Wird jetzt ja eh lustig, wenn Trump jetzt irgendwie
Grönland haben will, dann finde ich, kann man ja auch mal diese FIFA-WM boykottieren.
Das wäre aber eben eine geile Maßnahme.
Das wird ihn bestimmt richtig ärgern.
Aber darum soll es erstmal gar nicht gehen, sondern es geht um ein Fußballspiel.
Fußballspiel, ein Fußballspiel, was stattgefunden hat im letzten November im
Rahmen der Europa League.
Das ist so diese zweite,
Bundesliga? Ja, also auf europäischer Ebene ist das quasi die zweite Liga. Nach der,
Champions League.
Und darunter gibt es dann noch die Conference League, das ist dann die dritte Liga.
Das ist dann die unterste Schublade.
Ja, ist auch lustig. Hast du interessanteren Dorfvereine am Start,
wenn du daran teilnehmen kannst.
Das macht auf jeden Fall deutlich nettere Ausflüge.
Naja, auf jeden Fall spielten im Rahmen dieser Europa League in Birmingham die
Vereine von Aston Villa und Maccabi Tel Aviv und das war dann aber nicht so schön,
weil die Polizei in Birmingham beschlossen hat, dass das alles viel zu gefährlich
wäre hier mit diesen israelischen Fans.
Das gibt alles nur Ärger und hat von daher eine Teilnahme der Auswärtsfans verhindert.
Also haben sozusagen gesagt, das machen wir nicht mit, das wird jetzt hier einfach untersagt.
Das ist ja leider sowieso ein ganz blöder Trend in Europa, dass Auswärtsbesucher
von Spielen ausgeschlossen werden.
Aber die Begründung war halt wiederum mal die Sicherheit und es sei ja hier
irgendwie mit Protesten zu rechnen.
Wir erinnern uns da noch etwas aufgeheiztere Stimmung rund um den Israel-Gaza-Konflikt.
Aber vor allem bezogen die sich auf Vorfälle, ähnliche Vorfälle,
die es ein Jahr vorher in Amsterdam gegeben hat.
Und ja, da haben sie auch einen entsprechenden Bericht vorgelegt.
Und naja, dieser Bericht war dann doch etwas umstritten, weil er ein paar Fehler enthielt.
Unter anderem, dass das nie stattgefunden hat?
Naja, also doch, diese Ausschreitungen in Amsterdam, die gab es so.
Allerdings sprachen sie dann von 5000 Einsatzkräften, die vor Ort dann nötig
gewesen wären. Es waren aber nur 1200.
Irgendwelche israelischen Fans hätten Muslime angegriffen und in den Fluss geworfen.
Das gibt es auch keinen Beleg dafür.
Und es ging aber noch ein bisschen weiter, indem sie auch noch andere Spiele
zitiert haben, wo es auch schon Ärger gab, nämlich jetzt konkret mit Maccabi Tel Aviv.
Also in Amsterdam, das war glaube ich eine andere Mannschaft,
das weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht.
Unter anderem monierten sie ein im November 23 durchgeführtes Spiel von West
Ham United gegen Maccabi Tel Aviv.
Das war ganz schlimm damals.
Das ist ja gar nicht stattgefunden, oder?
Nee, Maccabi Tel Aviv hat in den letzten 25 Jahren kein Spiel gegen West Ham United gemacht.
Und ich glaube auch davor, ich glaube, es gab noch nie eins.
Und ja,
und dementsprechend wurde dann schon immer gemunkelt. Ja, mit habt ihr da vielleicht,
ein bisschen mit der AI rumgespielt.
Und er so, nee, nee, auf gar keinen Fall. Wir haben das alles gegoogelt.
Also sozusagen total zuverlässige Quellen benutzt.
Naja, wie ihr euch schon denken könnt, mussten sie jetzt eingestehen,
dass dann doch zur Überarbeitung dann doch...
Redaktionelle Überarbeitung, das ist immer nur redaktionelle Überarbeitung.
Und kam dann halt auch nochmal so, wegen der Flüchtigkeitsfehler und so,
kam dann doch Co-Pilot zum Einsatz von Microsoft und tja, da hat ihn wohl die
AI ein paar Fakten hinein halluziniert und jetzt ist natürlich die Aufregung groß.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ja schon gekündigt wurde, der Polizeichef,
aber ich glaube, das steht jetzt unmittelbar an.
Tja, so ist es halt.
Ist nicht immer schlecht, wenn die Polizei AI benutzt, ja? Wenn da nachher einer.
Den Hut nimmt, ist ja auch nicht so verkehrt.
Ja, vielleicht. Ein bisschen Innovationskraft. Vielleicht. Ich weiß ja nicht,
ob das jetzt generell ein nicht so wünschenswerter Polizeichef war oder ob das
jetzt quasi einfach einen Fehlgriff war, der Konsequenzen hatte.
Auf jeden Fall, ich habe so den Eindruck,
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wir dieses Jahr noch einiges in diese Richtung
hören und dass dann so langsam aber sicher wahrscheinlich so ein kollektives Lernen einsetzen wird,
wo man so feststellt, vielleicht nicht für diese Art von Anwendungen,
lieber für andere Anwendungen.
Also dass man jetzt mal lernt, mit diesen Werkzeugen, die ja manchmal ganz hilfreich
sein können, umzugehen, aber auf gar keinen Fall Faktenberichte damit überarbeiten
lassen, das macht sich gar nicht gut.
Ja, jetzt haben wir noch einen Termin noch zu verkünden.
Oh ja.
Ja, und zwar ist ja Winter. Dann kann man ja auch auf einen Winterkongress gehen.
Gibt es nämlich einen in der Schweiz.
Der Winterkongress der digitalen Gesellschaft. Eine kleine, feine Schweizer Version des C3.
Okay.
Bold move. findet statt am 20. und 21.
Februar 2026 in der Roten Fabrik in Zürich.
Drei parallele Tracks mit 30 Vorträgen und Workshops und eine Keynote von Sophie
Achermann, die ich nicht kenne.
Und zum Ausklang noch eine Jubiläumsveranstaltung zum 15. Geburtstag der digitalen
Gesellschaft. Na bitte.
15.
Geburtstag?
Okay, ich wollte gerade sagen.
1, 5, nein, nein. Genau, findet ihr alles unter winterkongress.cz.
Sophie Achermann ist Expertin für öffentlichen Diskurs, Co-Gründerin und Geschäftsführerin
der Public Discourse Foundation, eine Stiftung,
welche die Erforschung und Stärkung des öffentlichen Diskurses im Internet bezweckt.
Laut Wikipedia. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, Wikipedia. 25. Geburtstag.
Hm, stimmt.
Siehst du? Ich habe gedacht, ich bringe noch eine Wikipedia unter. Zack.
Haben wir das überhaupt schon gewürdigt?
Nee, ich glaube, wir haben letztes Mal den 10-Jährigen und 15-Jährigen gewürdigt.
Und dann erzählst du immer, ja, und damals Wikipedia und im Chaos-Radio haben
wir einen Wikipedia-Artikel gelesen und Pfeffer hat angerufen.
Nein, Pfeffer hat nicht angerufen. Wir haben keinen Wikipedia-Artikel gelesen,
wir haben einen geschrieben.
Das geht ja heute nicht mehr.
Editiert.
Oh! Das geht heute auch nicht mehr. Ich habe das sofort geblockt.
Hast du die mal gehört, die Folge?
Ja, vor 15 Jahren oder wann. Die
habe ich gehört, als Wikipedia gegründet wurde. Nee, ich höre sie mir an.
Wikipedia wurde drei Jahre vorher gegründet. Ich kann dir sehr empfehlen.
Chaos Radio 91, meine absolute Lieblingsfolge von Chaos Radio.
Weil die so schön...
Was habt ihr denn editiert? Habt ihr wenigstens einen ordentlichen Edit-War gestartet?
Ja, alles. Das war ja das Geile daran. Also wir hatten ja irgendwie zwei von
dem frühen deutschen Wikipedia-Team dabei.
Da hast du deinen Doktor-Titel.
Nee, das war sehr lustig, weil wir uns eben, ich meine, du weißt ja,
damals war sozusagen alles neu.
So dieses, wie man kann das selber editieren und so weiter, diese ganzen Fragen kamen natürlich.
Und zu dem Zeitpunkt war ja auch diese Wikipedia-Community ja noch sehr überschaubar
groß. Also das Bestand von, was weiß ich, vielleicht aus...
Keine Ahnung, zweistellige Zahl von aktiven Leuten, wenn überhaupt.
Und die hörten natürlich dann auch alle live bei dieser Sendung zu.
Und dann kam irgendwann Holgi und meinte so, wie, ich kann jetzt hier irgendwie
alles editieren? Ja, klar. Dann drückst du auf Edit und dann schreibst da was rein.
Kann ich jetzt hier reinschreiben? Gott ist doof oder was?
Und wir so, ja, könntest du machen.
Dann mach ich das mal. Und dann fing er da an, irgendwie mit seinem Windows
3.11 irgendwie rum zu hantieren versucht, irgendwie diese Webseite zu machen,
während wir uns weiter unterhielten.
Und dann kam er dann irgendwann auf diese Webseite und meinte so, das steht da schon.
Und weil wir halt live on air waren, da hat es halt irgendeiner reingeschrieben.
Woraufhin dann aber zwei Minuten später irgendwie, weil natürlich auch alle
Admins zugehört haben, haben sie dann die Seite gesperrt.
Also wir konnten sozusagen in dieser Sendung diese vollständige Dynamik,
wie so Wikipedia funktioniert, konnten wir einfach so live durchziehen. Das war grandios.
Ich dachte, sie hätten festgestellt, dass dein Beleg fehlt. Dass es Gott gibt.
Es gibt sogar diesen Link auf diesen Edit. Der ist ja noch in der Datenbank drin.
Und das war alles ganz lustig.
Verstehe.
Das war's dann heute. Heute haben wir nicht so viel zu erzählen.
Nicht so viel passiert. Wir warten immer noch auf die Grünland-Invasion und
dann haben wir wieder mehr Themen.
Sei mutig! Wikipedia! Das war ja immer das Motto der Wikipedia.
Sei mutig?
Ja.
Das muss aber lange her sein.
Wir reden von einer Sendung vom 28. April 2004.
Sei mutig, war das Motto der Wikipedia?
Ja, sei mutig, schreib rein, gestalte mit, editiere, trage bei.
Man musste den Leuten noch antrainieren, Sachen ins Internet reinzutun.
Ja, stimmt.
Das war nicht normal. Das war anfänglich, hat man Internet geguckt.
Das war, wie mit dem Fernseher kann ich interagieren.
Ja.
Und jetzt wie im Moment, ich kann da was reinschreiben. Ja, stimmt,
das musste man, also kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Heute kriegst du Leute nicht davon weg, dass sie was ins Internet reinmachen.
Na?
Ja.
Jetzt, früher, haben sie sich geziert.
Also, wobei, sage ich mal, Leuten zu ihrem möglichen Wissen irgendwo ins Internet
schreiben zu können. Und dann so, hier, weißt du was?
Schreib das mal da rein. Mansplaining bitte da lang.
Also hat sich jetzt ein Erfolgsmodell. Das hat lange Zeit Kräfte gebunden.
Jetzt ist die Wikipedia so ein bisschen fertig, oder? Also ist sie fertig geschrieben?
Ach, Quatsch.
3.089.872 Artikel in deutscher Sprache.
Könnte man jetzt eigentlich mal mit einer AI noch ein paar dazuschreiben lassen.
Und ein paar Englisch übersetzen. Ja,
Also die Wikipedia hat natürlich tatsächlich, auch für die Wikipedia,
ist AI jetzt ein Problem.
Sie ist das primäre Lehrmaterial für jedes LLM. Das erste, was man dem Ding
sagt, so ja hier, lies mal bitte kurz Wissen der Welt.
Und dann sagt Bescheid, dann bestehen wir hier kurz die Abiturprüfung und dann
können wir weiterreden.
Gleichermaßen haben sie natürlich Herausforderungen wie,
also für wen sie das da machen, als spendenbasiertes Community-Projekt von besonderer
Relevanz, das aber jetzt eben auch droht, von seinen künstlich intelligenten
Leserinnen gefressen zu werden.
Hast du schon deine AI-Learning-Materialspende dieses Jahr gemacht?
Normalerweise bettelt da ja immer so ein Jimmy Wales in den Weihnachtsmonaten.
Eine AI-Spende? Ich habe jetzt erstmal gerade den Edit hier, wo Gott tot ist, genau.
Tot oder doof?
Tot. Ich hatte doof in Erinnerung. Gott ist tot. Stand dann da auf einmal drin.
Findet hier alles in den tollen...
Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass das entweder in einem Artikel zu,
wahrscheinlich Nietzsche drinstehen sollte.
Was? Dass Gott doof ist oder tot?
Ja. Also tot. Und dann oder in, also sprach Zarathustra, oder?
Naja.
Das ist auf jeden Fall die Quellenangabe dazu.
Geistwesen. Wolkenwesen. Leute, es zählen nur Podcasts.
Das sind die einzigen Götter, die ihr verehren müsst.
So, so.
So sieht das aus. Leute, das war's. Euer Laubbuch Nespolitik von heute.
Ja, sagen wir Tschüss, oder?
Ciao, ciao.
Ja, Gott ist auf jeden Fall so ein Beitrag, wo es dann schnell mal zu einem
sogenannten Edit War kommen kann.
Also als Edit War bezeichnet man eben das gehäufte Abändern eines Artikels,
meist wechselseitig von Vertretern unterschiedlicher Standpunkte.
Es gibt ja natürlich eine ganze Menge Themen, wo man eben nicht zwangsläufig
einer Meinung ist, auch wenn man die gleiche Sprache spricht.
Und wenn es auffällt, und es fällt in der Regel schnell auf,
dass eben so ein Artikel unter Beschuss ist, weil der eine sieht es halt so,
der andere sieht es halt so, dir werden sicherlich noch ein paar gute Beispiele einfallen.
Ich könnte jetzt zum Beispiel bei Gott in der Wikipedia einfach mal reinschreiben, Gott ist doof.
Das könntest du mal, du könntest das mal jetzt reinschreiben und ich könnte
garantieren, dass diese Sendung auf gar keinen Fall überlebt.
Und da zieht sich halt sofort der demokratischen Kontrolle durch all die anderen
Nutzer und du wirst natürlich relativ schnell jemanden finden.
Es sei denn, der sich damit nicht einkam, es sei denn, alle anderen sind der
Meinung Gottes gesperrt.
Dann wirst du damit irgendwie eine neue Wahrheit erfunden haben.
Wow. Ja, mach doch mal. Ja, dann mach ich das mal. Erzählt mal was, ich muss dir tippen.
Guck mal bei Gott, genau. Wir erzählen derweil nochmal was. Wobei sowas natürlich
eher unter Vandalismus fällt. Also einfach stupide Sachen einfach reinzuschreiben.
Und da würden wir dann eher so gegen vorgehen, dass wir einfach dann die Nutzer
sperren. Also wir können halt gucken, welche IP-Adresse hat das verfasst.
Und wenn jetzt jemand da rumnervt, dann kann man den einfach mal für eine Stunde
oder für zwei oder wenn der ganz da rumnervt, dann kann man den einfach mal
für einen Tag sozusagen vor die Tür setzen und sagen so, der muss sich vielleicht
ein bisschen wieder abkühlen und kann dann wieder vorbeigucken.
Wenn ich auf Seite bearbeiten klicke, dann steht da Dummdi-Dumm als einziger
Text, den ich bearbeiten kann.
Dann hat es jemand abgenommen. Wir sind ja jetzt dabei,
die Leute zu wilden Taten zu überreden, aber du kannst jetzt mal,
also du hast ja kein Account, du kannst jetzt Gott auf deine Beobachtungsliste
setzen und dann würdest du auch schnell mitbekommen, dass sich da was getan
hat. Es hat sich schon was getan.
Mittlerweile steht überhaupt nichts mehr da, also da stand sehr viel über Glaubenskonzept und so.
Mittlerweile steht da nur noch God is great. Ich sehe das hier übrigens gerade,
es gibt übrigens einen IRC-Kanal auf IRC-Freenote.net unter lattensound.derc.wikipedia
sieht man alle Änderungen.
Da sehe ich hier gerade, also Gott wurde von IP-Adresse 217-231-82 geändert,
kurze Zeit später von IP-Adresse 80-129-253.9.
Wir kennen eure Namen, ihr habt keine Chance.
Jetzt gibt es schon die nächste Änderung. Diesmal von Paddy und...
Gott ist tot. Oh Gott, jetzt haben wir der Wikipedia hier wirklich Stress erzeugt.
Das wollten wir natürlich nicht, aber es wird sich selbst heilen,
das funktioniert halt wunderbar, weil es gibt hier eine definierte Machtstruktur,
unter Wikipedia Doppelpunkt Machtstruktur auch detailliert aufgeführt.
Mit unterschiedlichen Rollen. Also da gibt es halt erstmal so die unknown users,
das sind halt die Leute, die sich nicht dort registrieren und die einfach nur
als IP-Adresse dort auftauchen.
Dann gibt es eben die registrierten Benutzer, die dürfen auch alles ändern,
die dürfen auch Artikel umbenennen, also verschieben, Redirects-Umleitungen
von dem einen Begriff auf den anderen einrichten.
Aber sie dürfen nicht... Das hat sich gerade geheilt, ja. Sie dürfen keine Artikel löschen.
Genau, das dürfen wir Administratoren. Genau. Derer gibt es,
glaube ich, derzeit so 30 in der Deutschen.
In der Deutschen sind es doch ein bisschen mehr, oder? Ich habe neulich mal
geschaut, da waren es 30.
Ich hätte ja schon mal so 50 getippt oder so, aber ich bin dir auch nicht so
ganz sicher. Auf jeden Fall, ja, Administratoren sind Leute, denen wir vertrauen.
Also, wo wir sicher sind, wie groß geschrieben, ja.
Nein, das sind Leute, wo man sagen kann, die sind schon eine Zeit lang beim
Projekt dabei. Die haben bisher gute Arbeit geleistet.
Die stehen nicht im Verdacht, dass sie irgendwelchen Nonsens machen,
sondern die helfen gerne anderen neuen Nutzern noch aus.
Und dann kriegen die Adminrechte, das heißt, die haben dann solche Möglichkeiten,
dass sie einen Artikel löschen dürfen, sie dürfen Benutzer sperren.
Zwischenfrage, weist gerade im Chat darauf hin, dass es 60 Admins sind.
Zwischenfrage, ich bin nicht mehr in der Lage, die Seite zu ändern.
Dann ist die Seite jetzt gerade vor dem Administrator gesperrt worden.
Ein Administrator gerade zur Tat geschrieben wurde. Also ich bin jetzt nur noch
in der Lage, den Quelltext zu betrachten.
Wir haben jetzt halt alle total verrückt gemacht und jeder möchte das gerne
mal ausprobieren. Dann haben die gesehen, okay, jetzt haben wir hier einen totalen Edit-War.
Das wollen wir jetzt verhindern. Dann wird die Seite jetzt erstmal gesperrt.
Jetzt wird erstmal, solange die Sendung läuft über Gott, wird jetzt erstmal nicht diskutiert.
Weil diskutiert kann, ne? Diskutieren auf der Diskussionseite. Aus, aus, aus!